ça fait près de deux ans que gerald khoo
nous n'a pas vu ses trois filles à l été
2010 9 elle a été acceptée comme
réfugiés palestinienne au canada mais
les petites sont encore coincés à gaza
avec son mari à mort et à bolton en tout
cas j'essaie de les faire venir ici
explique-t-elle mais c'est un long
processus
les violences des derniers jours ne font
qu'exacerber son angoisse la semaine
dernière elle était au beau milieu d'un
appel vidéo avec sa famille
quand un raid aérien frappé tout près de
l'appartement juste les stones
christophe crémer ma fille a laissé
tomber le téléphone et elle a commencé à
crier je pensais que je les avais perdu
chaque jour dit elle je prie pour qu'il
y ait un cessez le feu et que je puisse
dormir de nouveau on appelle ans et
aussi par le premier ministre canadien
le canada est en train d'appeler pour un
cessez le feu et on va travailler avec
nos partenaires à l'international a pour
qu'ils retirent mais juste un être doux
reste très prudent il se garde bien de
montrer du doigt un des deux cas on est
de tout coeur avec les israéliens et les
palestiniens qui vivent des moments
extrêmement difficiles maintenant s'il y
un désir mais là c'est ce qui se fait de
façon fidèle à ses prises de position
antérieures
le npd déplore le manque de fermeté de
town vers israël notre chef du npd jack
layton a fait une intervention demandé
au gouvernement libéral de mettre fin à
la vente d'armes en israël le temps que
les violations des droits humains se
poursuivre
mais une intervention plus musclée de
pays occidentaux comme le canada serait
surprenante selon cet observateur la
personne peut se mettre les pieds dans
cette problématique là alors où on est
dans la violence économique un peu
partout et dans des processus de
déconfinement extrêmement complexe
surtout dans un dossier aussi polarisant
que le conflit israélo palestinien
peu importe la position que comprendra
on va se faire évidemment attaqué il
tergiverse il restait loin d'une prise
de position politique au tempérament à
care about having mac et sur tout ce
qu'elle espère c'est que sa famille
pourra fuir la violence de gaza le plus
tôt possible et si laurence martin radio
canada ottawa